parce qu'elle crée du lien social
qu'elle permet à chacun de s'exprimer et
de s'épanouir les associations sont
indispensables au Bien Vivre Ensemble
composante essentielle du développement
durable c'est pourquoi la communauté
d'agglomération Les a toujours soutenues
que ce sont les subventionnants en
mettant leur disposition des équipements
dans lesquels ils peuvent se réunir ou
alors proposant des services petit tour
d'horizon tu es prématistes on y va
40 ans les associations participent à
l'essor de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
elles sont aujourd'hui 1400 à intervenir
dans tous les domaines du sport aux
loisirs en passant par la solidarité ou
l'engagement citoyen et toute partage
les mêmes valeurs de cohésion sociale
mais comment cela a-t-il commencé
lorsque les premiers habitants ont
commencé à arriver bien souvent
le quartier dans lequel ils emménagaient
n'étaient pas n'était pas terminé
autour des résidences il y avait encore
encore des chantiers les communes ne
disposent pas encore de services
municipaux
étoffé pour prendre en charge justement
l'arrivée des habitants donc la seule
solution qu'on les habitants et bien
c'est de se tourner les uns vers les
autres de se regrouper naturellement
entre eux pour organiser la vie commune
et c'est comme ça que la vie associative
va se développer et c'est comme ça
qu'elle va prendre de l'importance
l'association
par définition ça crée du lien entre les
gens et ça et ça contribue à donner une
identité et une âme au territoire ça
c'est évident et là effectivement tout
le monde y a intérêt les institutions
politiques aussi vont beaucoup appuyer
au départ au départ ce mouvement et qui
va fortement influencer la vie politique
locale et c'est ainsi que la tradition
associative va se perpétuer à 50 ans en
Yvelines aujourd'hui encore elles sont
plus que jamais actives sur le
territoire exemple avec bleu oxygène
développement et la librairie
associative millefeuille attrape qui
allie développement durable engagement
citoyen insertion professionnelle et
solidarité c'est ici entrer vous allez
voir l'idée c'est de récupérer des
livres aux particuliers aux médiathèques
de les remettre en vente de l'étrier
donc ici la salle c'est la partie
librairie donc les personnes arrivent et
c'est la première pièce qu'il rencontre
c'est la pièce on va dire boutique donc
vous pouvez acheter les livres de poche
entre 50 centimes 1 € et on va jusqu'à
des livres jusqu'à maximum ici ça doit
être autour de 6 euros tous les livres
qu'on récupère en fait sont triés un par
un ceux qui ne bombent ne coïncide plus
avec pas à l'actualité mais vraiment de
son vraiment dépassés ou trop abîmés on
va récupérer les cartons le papier lui
va dans une entreprise d'insertion à
Coignières nouvelle attitude qui eux
revendent à des papiers nous on ne tire
aucun bénéfice de du papier
en revanche on récupère les cartons et
avec les cartons on refabrique en fait
toute la partie papeterie de la
librairie on a des gens qui viennent qui
s'installent qui lisent qui repartent on
n'est pas sur quelque chose de de
d'achat obligatoire
quand les livres arrivent ici on a
développé une un espace de vente sur
Internet c'était la garantie de pouvoir
maintenir nos prix bas ici plutôt que de
tenter d'augmenter les prix ici
on développe un autre circuit de vente
ça y est arrivé qu'on est des qu'on
récupère des des livres qui ont des
valeurs autour de 500 600 euros
ici ce sont des livres scolaires donc on
a un espace sur le livre scolaire sur
les dictionnaires qu'on maintient ce
sont des espaces les gens viennent se
servir c'est gratuit c'est pour que ben
voilà des associations d'aide aux
devoirs là on a hier une association qui
est venue qui organise des convois pour
l'Afrique
voilà l'atelier de confection donc de
tous les articles qui sont fabriqués et
oui la librairie est aussi un chantier
d'insertion professionnelle et embauche
des personnes éloignées de l'emploi donc
éloigné de l'emploi je pense ces 10 ans
de chômage autour de on peut monter
jusqu'à même des 30 ans sans activité la
reprise d'activité ici c'est à dire qui
est sous la forme d'un contrat de
travail un salaire redynamise forcément
faut dire ça réinjecte dans le dans la
réalité et cette énergie là en fait
repart également sur la recherche
d'emploi il travaille six mois ici les
personnes travaillent 20h par semaine à
la librairie Les bénéficier également
d'un d'autres accompagnements pendant la
durée du chantier c'est-à-dire un
accompagnement professionnel l'objectif
étant de retrouver un emploi à la sortie
du chantier un travail et un engagement
efficace et louable qu'il faut bien sûr
saluer encourager et soutenir conscient
de cela la communauté d'agglomération
aide la vie associative locale à
s'épanouir et à se développer depuis 200
en mettant en place un service Vie
Associative
il y a des salles qui sont mises à
disposition pour pour permettre aux
associations de réunir leur assemblée
générale et puis c'est du matériel quand
les associations organisent des
événements le service Vie associative a
d'abord
recensé les associations combien il y
avait d'associations à Saint-Quentin ce
fichier
est aussi un annuaire qui est sur le
site internet de la communauté
d'agglomération donc c'est aussi un
moyen de valoriser les associations
d'une partenaire et faire connaître donc
conseil au projet associatifs donc on
reçoit des des porteurs de projets
associatifs et
on essaye de les accompagner tout au
long de leur démarche de création
d'associations dans le cadre des aides
apportées par le service Vie associative
compléter notre dispositif d'aide par
par la mise en place d'un centre de
documentation avec les ouvrages les
ouvrages indispensables pour quand on
crée une association pour faire
sélectionner une association des
services complétés par un large
programme de formation
pour les aider à faire fonctionner leur
association donc c'est la comptabilité
c'est l'assurance et c'est le rôle du
dirigeant associatif c'est aussi des
formations informatiques l'éventail de
des outils à connaître pour le dirigeant
associatif vous en savez désormais un
petit peu plus sur la vie associative 50
images zoom désormais sur d'autres
aspects du développement durable tels
que des innovations en faveur des
circulations douces ou des
manifestations en faveur de
l'environnement voici les actus du mois
et non début de ses actus avec des jours
heureux les Happy Days grandes fêtes
consacrée aux abeilles se dérouleront
partout en France les 22 et 23 juin à
Saint-Quentin elle se tiendront à la
ferme pédagogique de la base de loisirs
et vous proposons de découvrir le rucher
avec des apiculteurs ou encore des
récoltes de miel miam un autre sujet qui
va faire le buzz mon alerte est un
service de la SNCF qui vous permet
d'être informé par courriel de l'état du
trafic en cas de fortes perturbations
sur votre ligne pour en bénéficier il
suffit de vous connecter sur
www.trocyr.com et d'enregistrer votre
trajet un service que vous pourrez
compléter par l'application SNCF
Transilien sur votre smartphone et pour
finir prenez date tout de suite le 23
juin à l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et
du climat vous propose de visiter une
maison bénéficiant de panneaux
photovoltaïques l'occasion de vous
renseigner concrètement sur les
avantages de l'énergie solaire et de
vous faire votre propre idée et comme on
dit les sons
un dossier bien vivre que vous pouvez
retrouver ainsi qu'un article sur
l'humorister Arnaud de sa mère un autre
sur le service d'autopartage en test à
50 ans Yvelines ainsi qu'un zoom sur les
associations médiévales de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans le petit
Quentin du mois de juin mais pour le on
retrouve tous nos rendez-vous culturels
du moment
merde